um who's to blame for what happened well
obviously it was a great shame that we
weren't able to reach
agreement with greater manchester we
tried extremely hard i had conversations
as did the prime minister's
advisor ed lister and the prime minister
himself spoke to
the mayor andy burnham yesterday but the
public health situation in greater
manchester was deteriorating
the evidence that we were receiving
about the capacity of
some of the hospitals in greater
manchester the number of cases the fact
was rising up
uh the age brackets to those people who
were in greater danger
of ill health it's gone down it uh no
well
there's the number of cases rising in
some parts of greater manchester it's
it seems there's some evidence of it um
plateauing in the center of manchester
perhaps linked to universities but
they're very clear
as well the very clear public health
advice
can i just finish answering the question
you know what you're saying is going up
and i'm saying
and blatantly it isn't because i'm not
sure i'm not sure what statistics you're
actually looking at there because the
the very clear public health advice that
i received
from the nhs from nhs england and the
chief medical officer
was that this was a serious and
deteriorating situation in greater
manchester
and that we needed to act that actually
we probably in honesty should have acted
a few days ago but we hadn't been able
to reach an agreement with the mayor of
greater manchester we wanted to do that
you've seen that we've been able to do
that i think very successfully with
other mayors and local leaders in the
north west like in
again that's not what they said they
said that they were forced into it
we have to respectfully disagree because
that's not the case we had very
productive conversations there
we've just been having yesterday we just
had very productive conversations with
dan jarvis
the mayor of sheffield and south
yorkshire and
those discussions are coming to a
conclusion this morning i hope
but we had to take action unfortunately
we weren't able to
reach an agreement with the local
leaders but the important message to
people in greater manchester
is that regardless of that we're
obviously going to do everything we can
to support people and businesses in
greater manchester
we've put in place a very extensive
package of support and that is there to
help them
through a challenging period okay um as
i said the figures from manchester the
city of manchester have gone
down um and that according to public
health
england i think it's it's important to
clarify because
this is a serious situation yes it is
and i know that there are some who are
downplaying what's happening in greater
manchester i think
i think that's ill-advised well some of
the local leaders in greater manchester
put out a statement
over the weekend saying that they didn't
think the situation was quite as serious
as
the public health professionals in the
government were saying there are more
covered patients
in hospitals in greater manchester at
the moment than there are in the whole
of the south
east and south west of england combined
so this is a serious situation we do
need to take action
we had spent 10 or 11 days discussing it
so it was right that we moved forward
put in place those measures i appreciate
how difficult they are
for people in greater manchester and
importantly that we put in place the
financial
and other support that's needed so if it
was so important why were you squabbling
over five million quid
it wasn't just about five million pounds
we had
dozens of conversations i'm afraid i'm
not going to get into a
point scoring argument but we simply
were not able to reach agreement
the mayor and local leaders were not
willing to agree
to the package of support that we wanted
to put in place
and i completely understand that as a
leader of
a city you want the absolute best for
your local residents i do as a
constituent cmp
for my own constituency but as a
government we have to act with fairness
and be proportionate to what we're doing
elsewhere in the country and we had
offered
and had been accepted a package of
support for other places the neighbours
of greater manchester in the northwest
the liverpool city region
and lancashire i hope we're on the cusp
of an agreement
with south yorkshire and andy burnham
was adamant
that he had to have a better deal than
his neighbors
i understand where he's coming from as i
say but that's not the way the
government can act we have to act
in a fair way which provides a broadly
similar package of support to all parts
how fair was it that he found out live
on the telly he didn't
they were holding a new a phone up and
he um he didn't
so when did he find out i phoned him and
told him did you win
well we had about we had several
conversations over the course of the
morning including with the prime
minister
and i told him the final news at two
o'clock
so you're showboating well i say i i i'm
not in the slightest bit interested
in point scorings isn't about
personalities or press conferences on
the steps of town halls it
in the end it's about an important
public health
situation and it's about ensuring the
people of greater manchester
now get the support that they deserve
okay just just to
i just want to ask you about what's
going on with south yorkshire and then
sheffield and we'll come back to
manchester
so from what you're saying about dan
jarvis and also uh south yorkshire it
looks as though they're going into tier
three
well it's not right for me to preempt um
a full statement that the prime minister
and
dan jarvis will make later today but we
have had very
uh successful conversations with him and
with the leaders of south yorkshire
again there's a serious situation there
and rightly
uh they wanted to take action we've
discussed that over the course of
yesterday
and earlier this morning and an
announcement we made shortly
and those conversations more productive
than they have been with greater
manchester
well we've actually had very productive
conversations with local leaders
in all the parts of the country that
we've worked with so far greater
manchester is the only one where we were
not able in the end to secure an
agreement
but i don't want to overstate that
because actually some of the local
leaders there like
sir richard lee's the long-standing
leader of manchester city council
david greenhouse of bolton council were
extremely
helpful and constructive they fought for
their city
and their their residents understandably
but they saw the need for us to come
together and have as united a public
health message
as possible my door is always open to
them and indeed to andy burnham
to discuss how we move forward and that
the extensive package of support which
is there
can now be put at the service of the
people of greater manchester so the 60
million pounds is still on the table
well it's more than just on the table
it's there it has manchester's name on
it
and i want to ensure that it gets into
the hands of local business people
particularly the small businesses of
greater manchester
some of which are now going to have to
close hopefully only for a short period
of time for 28 days
in order to bear down on the virus how
long is that 60 million quid supposed to
last
for in other words how long is the tier
3 lock down in manchester
it's 28 days the lockdown at which point
the
there'll be a review on both sides
obviously informed by
public health england and the joint
biosecurity center
let's hope that we won't need to extend
it thereafter
but we've tried to put in place a very
broad package of support
remember i know there's a debate about
the 60 million pounds
but actually that's only one part a
relatively small element of a much
broader
package of support you have the job
support scheme that will offer
people who are not able to work
two-thirds of their unearned wages
we've got business grants we've got the
cut-in vat the cut in business rates
so there's a broad package of support
and for greater manchester
there's not only the 60 million there's
a 22 million for extra
support for contact racing so that that
system can work at its absolute best
and also we're providing a very
significant additional amount of money
for local councils
so the total package of additional
support for greater manchester
is likely to be well over 150 million
pounds
building on all of the work that we've
done together since the start of the
pandemic
um something the prime minister didn't
mention in his briefing yesterday was
about gyms
in greater manchester are they allowed
to stay open or not
um i think that gyms are being asked to
close
um but you'll have to look on gov.uk
when
or we can revert to you when the
regulations are published
but we've adopted the same model as
lancashire
is having as the nearest neighbor of
greater manchester
okay interesting that we don't know the
answer to that
um what is the actual exit strategy for
regions that are in tier three
well as i say they will be in this
position for 28 days
only at which point there will be a
review point on both sides i hope that
the
good relations that we have in most
parts of the country will enable us to
do that in a very amicable way to really
address
what is the public health situation is
the area able to move out we're also
working
criteria though well that's there's a
range of different factors it's not
purely
the rate of incidence of the virus
important though that is
it also we also look at the particular
settings how it's playing in the
different age brackets
you know obviously those people of a
younger age are much less likely to get
seriously
unwell also i think this is an important
point to look at the state of play in
local hospitals
how much capacity is there how many
coveted patients are
unfortunately coming into icu that was
one of the factors that particularly
played on our mind
with respect to greater manchester in
london
the mayor and the government have worked
with public health england to devise
some trigger points
which are not an exhaustive list but are
a guide
to residents and to businesses in london
as to
the sorts of things we would be looking
to if london were able to come out of
tier 2 where it currently is today
and we've made a similar offer to other
places like greater manchester that they
could work with public health england
to devise things which would be in the
public domain it could give people a
really good guide
as to what the future holds you told me
i had to sit outside when i had lunch
with my colleagues the other day i was
freezing i had my coat on and that's not
the case at all you can have a working
lunch inside
uh well i believe you can but um i think
that's a
um a a a loophole that's being closed
oh is that okay uh talk to me about did
i also read that the mayor of london
wanted the 10 p.m curfew lifted
well i don't know i think you'd have to
ask sadiq khan that question he as far
as i can remember was
the one who proposed the 10 p.m curfew
i mean i think look we're dealing with a
rapidly developing
situation here i appreciate it so i
appreciate that people's views will
change over time
all of our views to some extent have
changed over time but either way it's
going to
stay in place but you know he like kia
starmer has
had a whole series of of different
policies over time
we will obviously keep having to look at
the evidence the advice that we've
received is the 10 pm curfew
does help to reduce the amount of
interaction between people
in social settings and therefore to have
an impact on the virus
okay let me just put this to you if i
may apparently there's an algorithm
that has been developed by oxford
university scientists suggesting
that if we shield five percent of brits
we could see a massive reduction in the
number of deaths
and it would be much cheaper than uh all
these regional or perhaps a circuit
breaker lockdown
well i've seen this argument and
obviously i'm not a scientist so i'm
probably
not best placed to give you the best
advice but the
the advice that i've received is to
treat
that proposition with a degree of
caution because remember there are lots
of people in this country living in
multi-generational families
those people are more likely to be in
deprived households they're also more
likely to be
bame households and so it's quite
difficult
to shield the most vulnerable people in
society completely
because of the nature of some of uh the
households in which people live
also the virus has a habit of finding
like water fight
going through cracks to find its way
into settings even if people go to quite
a lot of trouble
to shield themselves and there's there's
no country in the world that's managed
to successfully
shield to sequester a group of people
for a long enough period to ensure that
everybody else
can go out and you know enjoy their
lives to the full
so i would i would treat that with a
degree of caution we have
of course in the past had a shielding
policy for the clinically extremely
vulnerable
they weren't actually just the elderly
it was a very broad range people
including 80
000 children we have prepared further
advice there
which can be deployed if necessary but
it will be a different approach to
in the past where we'd say to people
that they can go out they can go to the
shops and so on but they need to
exercise a high degree of caution
because of the nature of their
underlying health issues let's send
where we started with andy burnham
should we i mean
it's a win-win for him really isn't he's
come across as a working-class hero and
all of those
red wall um constituencies that you
wanted that you won over
at the last election are going to be
looking at the westminster elite and
thinking
he maybe will vote labour at the next
election
well i'm not interested in showboating
or indeed in personalities
i'm interested in public health we
discussed with leaders in greater
manchester
so for 10 or 11 days how we could take
action
against a very serious public health
crisis
in the city region but by saying that
forgive me mr jerry but by saying that
he's suggesting that he is not
interested
in in the health of you can you ask me a
question about whether this will lead to
how people vote in a future election and
say that is not in
my thoughts what i want to do is take
decisive action now to keep people safe
i also want to ensure that we protect
their livelihoods by putting in place
the right financial package
we will do that for greater manchester
people at home should know
that regardless of personalities we will
provide the support that they deserve
but we have very good relationships with
other local leaders in the northwest
we've talked about some of them
already and that's right central and
local government should be working
in harmony to try to tackle a national
crisis
are you suggesting for one moment that
that's not what mr burnham wanted
no you've asked me that question i said
that what i am doing
is trying to work as closely as possible
with local leaders
to ensure we put in place the right
measures for people in a timely fashion
that's exactly what
the government has done here that's what
the prime minister tried to do
yesterday so we've taken action now we
will be putting
in place these further restrictions but
please be assured
that all of the support the greater
manchester asked for
and needs will now be in place from this
week and a final thought
you said that he was chatting on the
phone to the prime minister
yesterday still couldn't reach a
conclusion how would you describe that
conversation was it bit tetchy
no the prime minister said uh that he
was very grateful for the hard work
that local leaders and other public
servants throughout greater manchester
done
so far he completely understood the
challenge in that city as across the
whole of the country
you know all leaders are grappling with
difficult challenges
but the prime minister was very clear
that we had to act
because that was the clear advice that
he had received from our medical
advisors and that we now needed to bring
these
agreements or discussions to a
successful conclusion so that
we could put in place the measures and
move forwards